[Music]
welcome to the second edition of
qualified I'm here with our chess club a
boy Harry Colson you may remember him
from do good don't even go there yeah so
here is his a Redemption
all right he was playing the Windham was
lion from last week
Jeffery Kendall Jeffery was in this
predicament as black and he decided
right he decided to defend the g6 he did
I was a little concerned though with
this pawn with his pawn right here so
before I actually did anything I took
this pawn with the rook oh no oh no I
did no I don't believe it Perry I don't
believe it I think I did take the pawn
with the rook why don't you get a second
chance if you got to go back in time
what would you obviously plan you know
what would you player of course I would
of course how to play that all right and
then I only have one move or Jeffery
dude and then I played that and I put
him in check all right now black X yes
three moves in this position and Jeffery
picks the roll exactly one and then it
was I think it was curtains for mr.
Leonard Wood chess team so I just took
right here and what he that's checkmate
yeah the slamma-jamma right there I
might have taken that move a couple
moves prior but I was I was worried
about that pawn but I ended up working
out for me and I got to put Jeffery and
checkmate and I was really happy because
he has Lindenwood chess on his jacket so
and you're against them up we know
they're just you know playing a college
chess persons pretty good yep yeah all
right gonna be good good luck Perry in
the subsequent rounds thank you I'm here
at the conclusion of round two with
fellow chess employee Nicholas risco he
had the pleasure of playing a Perry who
we just saw in round 2 so before I delve
in if he won or not let's see how he
plays the Italian games go heads they
have to go e4 e5 Knight f3 knight c6
Bishop c4 for the Italian and then parry
parry obviously doesn't know much about
chess sometimes so he still plays Knight
of 6 but Nicklaus does not
smash him with Knight to g5 would let's
see how Nicholas purse my grand master
might come I play
d3 man alright it's not as wild but you
get a wait to see what their plan is
well their plan is obviously to get that
Bishop out and castle yeah yeah to c5
obviously c5 then you Castle and then
they Castle and everybody's safe right
and then it's just d3 after the knight
move is also okay because if we go back
before Castle if we end up going with
Bishop and Castle we have to plate 93
well now III would have occurred yet
okay if you just Castle okay the night
comes out like g5 is still it won't work
because they just castles so you play d3
and it's the same exact position either
way not really but I don't have time to
get into so so okay so how did you end
up beating Perry in the end they to get
a point let's see it was ending up
playing moves like a 4 B 4 driving his
bishop away getting dark toward Bishop
on to b2 and rook a3 to use Queen e2
couple of moves create a battery and
just drive his King to a position
fortunate with trade Queens it was good
stuff alright Nikolas all right well
good luck in your subsequent rounds I
read the Fred action quads has concluded
and I'm here with a quad 3 co-champion
$18 winner
Azeem Aziz otherwise known as the
Facebook champion yeah cuz I only post
my wins on Facebook yes nobody knows the
actual truth alright so you had a tough
round 3 game but you're losing a little
bit but you guys a few tricks up your
sleeve huh
yeah I sacrificed my knight he thought
he had a free night so I took this pawn
over here in front of the king
and he took back with his queen uh-oh
which left the Queen and the king
exposed so the rooks were backing it up
and that makes me win the Queen there oh
yeah just like say up tip it over I'm
going home oh no actually he played a
little bit but it was just too powerful
for him after that and he eventually
resigned yeah it looks like you got a
good attack going haven't had a good
attack yeah alright Azim but hopefully
you've got to start playing in more
tournaments he's kind of shy away from
the tournaments but there's some wins
under your belt you had to get a little
confidence so maybe now I'll be ready to
play more tournaments all right well
it's always a pleasure fantastic thanks
sir
[Music]